assalamu alaykum wa rahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends before I start wanna praise
allah subhanho wa taala the most
merciful the most just or praises glory
and gratitude belong to him for the work
that we do now the reason I'm bringing
this video to your attention is because
it's something that I predicted now me
predicting something does not make me
like awliya or some fear or whatever it
may you may call it the reason why I'm
saying predicted is not this exact thing
that that was going to happen but these
future events of attacks that are going
to happen be it towards Muslims and
non-muslims that's why when a lot of
people come and say to me you know bro
Valley why did you find a need wasting
your time with the far-right or be it
with antrim charges followers why did
you find the need to do that and I just
want to highlight this issue not to
score a brownie point and say look I was
right he's wrong no but to raise
awareness to the problem that's
happening and that is escalating a man
happily goes into a mosque as you guys
know and just massacres a group of
worshippers with no remorse with no
remorse at all running them over as
their dead body lies on the floor now
what causes and what leads somebody to
come to that point where he is
absolutely careless well this man this
evil criminal as much as other criminals
out there as well these terrorists
actual terrorists and these people come
to this level how because it's brainwash
they've been brainwashed continuously
and sometimes we blame Facebook and
Instagram and this and that
no the mainstream media are as much to
blame and the fake news that are
circulated there sadly this has an
effect when you have images of there was
an actual image of a group of evil
Muslims raping a white girl and the
police are holding back the parents of
this white girl this was an image that
was made now when you have that kind of
propaganda being shared obviously people
are having this hatred us-built inside
them and when this is the same is done
on the newspapers on mainstream media on
Facebook continuously if I said to you
here is person a his name is John at the
from the get-go you're gonna be thinking
okay John is just John you know it
depends let's say the way he looks is
you might say you know what maybe him
thirty-five year old man whoever may be
like if I said to you know what John is
evil yeah
John is evil because of this and because
of that and I kept on repeating with you
continuously at one point you're going
to start to think John is evil yes John
is evil so this is why it's so dangerous
and I'm gonna play some clips I'm little
mini clips or my confrontation with
Roland sovereign with Tommy Robinson
with a V Yemeni with Antrim charges
follower Abdul Hakim and Britain first
Jada friends in here we won't look at
these clips and I just want you guys to
understand what they are saying
the first one is quite shocking it's
from wrong and sovereign let's hear it
for ourselves and surely I'm gonna come
and make a few valid points
like if I said same things to you try
about the hijab don't agree with it yeah
neither am I going to be receptive you
believe but this doesn't mean we depart
our ways how about practice I will go
with that so for example do we both
agree that rape is wrong yes do we both
agree that police people is wrong yes
now listen carefully to what she says
when I say should we live in harmony
both live in comedy no no so basically
I'm saying we both have something that
would both agree on killing is wrong
rape is wrong and we should live in
harmony right she says no that's one
clip let's go to the next one
[Applause]
[Music]
I do not come in peace but I come with a
sword I come to turn mother against son
against father against son mother
against son-in-law let me tell you if
you'd me because we're Christians and
I'm holding this cross okay that's
another clip now in that pub imagine
this shooter who cared that the massacre
in New Zealand if he's watching that and
he sees a young white lady saying to
another Muslim that no we should not
live in harmony and then he says you
know what let me cook and he comes
across my second video confront in
Britain first and she goes Matthew
chapter 10 verse 44 I did not come to
bring peace but I came to bring sword
okay now what do you think is gonna be
going through his head do you think if
you wanted to carry out the attacks he's
gonna say you know what these videos
have made me realize that actually no I
shouldn't do this or he's gonna think
you know what yeah you're right I don't
live in harmony yes Jesus did come to
spread the sword next video where I
confronted Tommy Robinson and his
accusations continuously the Quran says
kill their maim them behind me there's
these enemy combatants when I confronted
him
yeah now you tell me where in the Quran
the Sunna and the Islamic literature
they orders us muslim muslim i follow my
religion to every letter relevant he
says oh okay I went to Tony Robinson and
I asked him this very specific question
because he claims something he claims
that the Quran teaches the killing of
innocent people what Isis do the Quran
teaches this so now if he is true to his
claim he would say Ali of course this is
very easy for me open surah Baqarah open
surah tauba opened this verse it will
opened up this and this is why religion
teaches smutty would have reflected me
would have absolutely humiliate me but
he didn't why why did he not bring
substance to what he's claiming because
there is
no substance all he's doing is throwing
this rhetoric out there and his foot
soldiers are hearing it believing in it
and carrying out attacks now this last
one is actually this tournament of a guy
called every gay man who with his own
hands claims and admits that he is shot
innocent Palestinian kids in the head
[Music]
have you have you saw people like this
guy answer don't be shy don't be shy
comment on the Gaza Strip people like
this guy yes yes you have he has shot
innocent people no we're not gonna
finish any finish who go to the bonfire
this guy is the biggest terrorist ever
now he's claiming with his own mouth can
you imagine a Muslim saying yes I have
shot innocent non-muslims he would be
gone finished
this guy is travelling happily coming to
the UK like his happy days all day long
and last clip is a clip of me and one of
my teachers Sheikh Mohammed confronting
and talking to anthem charges follower
who someone who he knew carried out the
London Bridge attacks someone he knew
carried out attacks if you knew they
were gonna do would you go to the first
you simple
no it's because it's someone that you
knew aqui I'm saying if you knew they
said you were going to carry out the
attack right now yeah would you go to
the okay now the question that leads to
asked is this alley do you not have
nothing better to do why do you find the
need to confront these people from all
kinds of extremes yeah
the reason I find the need to do this is
because innocent blood is being spilled
yeah
it's innocent people if you look at it
attacks that happen from Isis from the
far-right terrorists the white
supremists who is suffering at the end
of it it's me and you you're going about
your business you're going about your
life you're the one who's been massacred
on the streets I'm going about my life
the people in New Zealand were going
about their life they went to Friday
prayers to pray they won't be to pray
just as much you might go to the church
to pray or whatever it may be they went
there and they got massacred this is the
reason why we are so stoned as a team
with Muslims that involved in the Dower
so much against this why because it's
the innocence blood has been spilt and
we need to carry on confronting these
people talking about this and making
Islamophobia a crime it should be a
crime because mainstream media how can
you be surprised if you're verifying
dehumanizing I went to Metro news a week
ago
a week ago this killer this murderer who
killed 50 Muslims was called an angelic
boy an angelic
boy can you hear what I'm saying
somebody he killed 50 people is an
angelic boy Shamima becomes son is a
jihadi baby can you imagine an innocent
baby that's born to this world yes is
called a jihadi baby somebody has killed
50 people massacred life is caught an
angelic boy do you know understand
what's happening this this hatred is
being spew and they don't even know
they're so used to it that this even
after the shooting scene is an energetic
point do you understand what I'm saying
so that's the reason why bombers and
sisters we're asking for you guys to
ensure like hell
and carry on helping brothers in the Dow
scene amazing works being done I want to
wrap up but this is the reason why I'm
telling you this was predicted not by me
by everyone and lots of Muslims are not
surprised do you think that almost I'm
surprised they know because we've been
vilified to a point where I want
children our babies are jihadis they are
born as a jihadi baby so this is the
reason why I'm sure above the sisters
whoever's kind of down okay then let's
not just be those who were just helping
humanitarian causes yeah whoever it may
be help it
there's brothership for example five
pillars be it IRR be it a Salaam what we
do not Salam be it yuckiness whoever it
may be help them because if not more
people are going to be massacred the way
to stop this is by stopping
vilifying the people otherwise we're
gonna have another Holocaust we're gonna
have the same thing that Nuremberg
Nuremberg where the Jews had to wear a
specific badge and slowly slowly they
were slaughtered don't think that Hitler
woke up one day and said to his
commanders yup guys get your guns that
working in the juice no it was a gradual
process go look what happened back then
one life the same thing is happening
history is repeating itself the Jews
they were drawn as like these big nose
ugly creatures why because for you to
get your soldiers to pull the trigger
first they needs to believe that these
people are a problem and they are not
human that's what you need to do because
otherwise they're not gonna kill they're
gonna say this is a human being yeah but
look these people are evil these were
taken over these people want to come you
know that all this kind of stuff then
he's gonna say okay now I'm ready to
kill why because he's a fret why would
somebody kill somebody that he doesn't
believe is a friend so that is the
reason why do not let history repeat
itself criminalize Islamophobia you can
criticize a religion the fact that we go
out there and do Dawa is the fact that
we're seeing ask us questions about our
religion criticize us ask about ask us
about why does it stop teach that that
is not the same as seen that insulting
swearing taking things out of context
what was the sisters that's why I don't
want to carry on any further insha'Allah
hope you guys have benefited from this
do share with your friends and family
may Allah bless you guys and I want to
thank everyone inshaallah
in my team my teachers who have helped
me inshaallah from to combat these
far-right
a terrorist and these Isis
scumbags who are killing innocent
non-muslims and Muslims less not suffer
at their hands in sha allah and put a
stop to this assalamualaikum
warahmatullah america